welcome back to this special edition of
hannity tonight crime continues to rise
in america's democrat-run cities
while the left refuses to take action
yesterday
a new york city man was arrested for
robbing a chase bank
it came just one day after he was
reportedly released from police custody
at the prosecutor's request for robbing
a different
chase bank and during the new york city
mayoral debate
one candidate maya wiley refused to
answer when asked about taking guns away
from new york city police officers
the backlash was so strong that her team
is now denying she wants to disarm the
cops
and meanwhile as shootings continue to
soar
in new york city former nypd police
chief terry monahan
said it was a mistake to disband the
anti-crime unit tasked with firearm
busts
without replacement the unit was
disbanded last
june amid widespread violence against
police and riots including
a july 15 incident that left monahan
himself injured terry monahan joins us
now with reaction
all right good evening how are you
good evening judge how you doing good
all right so you know we started with
i'm terrific thanks we started with one
guy's being released
after having robbed a chase bank and
while he's out
on nobel he robs another chase bank and
then he's released again
i mean you know when you were chief of
the department
life was a little different and the
criminals kind of got
you know they got a little more serious
uh in terms of
criminal justice and how they were being
handled
that that's a direct uh response to bail
reform
when you look at that individual you
were a judge
if you had discretion and this man just
robbed the bank and you were told he was
homeless
you would never let him walk back out on
the street but
under bail reform it's mandatory that
uh on a robbery third like that
you have to get an automatic ror no
matter how dangerous you are
so the one thing we've always asked
we're not looking to go back to exactly
the same bail laws we had before
but we elect judges people that we we
elect
appoint judges give them that discretion
if someone is dangerous to the community
that individual should not be put back
out on the streets right and and
you know the other part of it is if
you've got this guy who
jumps or or is able to leave on one
arrest or a bank goes out during his
bail and
then commits another robbery of a bank
what makes them think this guy is going
to show up for
trial anyway you and i both know he's
not going to show up for trial unless
he's brought in
on the day of trial and the chances of
that happening are slim to none
let's talk about this woman who's
running for mayor in new york city
this maya wiley what do you think of her
listen her statement the idea of
disarming cops is the most ridiculous
thing i ever heard in my life
we've had 700 people shot in this city
so far this year
our cops our great cops in new york city
have made over 1300 gun arrests how are
you making that gun arrest if you don't
have a gun on your side
it would just leave us with dead cops
all over the place
well you know what chief it's amazing
because we've already seen the problems
with
uh with defunding police and this woman
that you're seeing on the screen who's
running for mayor of new york city
you know she wants to take another
billion dollars from the nypd i mean
this is this is crazy town now
and i mean i'm gonna we only have about
10 seconds but
uh do what do you think can can new york
come back from this
absolutely yes and we are coming back
you have the greatest cops in the world
yes
yes they can you have the greatest cops
in the world here and they're going to
keep this city safe
all right thank you chief monahan stay
with us hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else